the White House and Congress are working
fast on a package to limit the economic
damage from the outbreak president Trump
wants to suspend the payroll tax
boosting Americans paychecks but
lawmakers are not convinced Paula Reid
is at the White House Paula what are the
chances of a deal like that coming
together a good morning Anthony the
White House is working with Democrats to
try to find some common ground but with
Congress scheduled to be out next week
there is skepticism about whether any
relief will come quickly now the White
House in addition to wanting to help
those impacted by the outbreak they also
hope that a payroll tax cut could offer
a boost to the economy which is central
to the president's reelection strategy
as a nation we can't be doing the kinds
of things we were doing a few months ago
at the White House coronavirus briefing
last night dr. Anthony pouchy urged
Americans to prepare for a new normal
you have to start taking seriously what
you can do now
that if and when the infections will
come and they will come it was a
remarkably different tone than the one
the president struck when he was on
Capitol Hill earlier it will go away to
stay calm the president was lobbying
Republican senators on a stimulus to
ease the economic impact of the outbreak
I was just with the Republican senators
and
they were just about all they're mostly
all there and there's a great feeling
about doing a lot of things the
proposals include assistance to those
without sick leave possible tax relief
to industries hit hardest by the
outbreak and a temporary payroll tax cut
through the end of the year that could
cost up to hundreds of billions of
dollars the payroll tax supports the
country's two biggest safety nets Social
Security and Medicare and the White
House has given no details on how it
would make up the lost revenue at some
point in the in the near future we will
outline a more detailed package for you
the idea was met with resistance among
Democrats and even some Republicans
aren't fully on board I don't know if a
payroll tax cut is the right stimulus
but we need something
meanwhile the coronavirus task force is
working to provide tips on how to stay
healthy
including avoiding large crowds will
they pence Trump campaigns suspend
campaign rallies and other activities I
think that'll be a decision that's made
literally on a day to day basis shortly
after that briefing the Trump campaign
announced a catholics for Trump
coalition of that next Thursday at an
arena in Wisconsin which seats thousands
it appears the administration's message
on large social gatherings is do as we
say not as we do Tony
Paula thank you